Oh guile American war hero dial America
I just you just exclaimed in america.you
class
hey u.s.a u.s.a it's in office nobody
wants to do the USA chant just as a
general note could you tone this down
sir flat top tank top - American flag
tattoos we get it you're American sir
I am just representing the country that
I love yeah so is Ken but he's not
dressed like a Japanese tourist going to
Manhattan for the first time okay guile
the reason I called you in is there's a
discrepancy on your application it says
that you fought in a war yeah fought in
the war a war I'm just gonna need to
clarify that fought for America and I
defeated the enemy with my flash kick
see that's where I'm losing you is I
can't see someone with your specific set
of skills fighting in a war where there
are guns you're just flipping up in the
air like a skeet shoot you'd be dead in
two seconds
there was no guns in this war and a
gunless war it was the no gun more of 63
where where was the no gun war of 663
how was the Europe war the Europe war
the one in Europe the Europe won that
war sorry what branch of the military
are you in again old Navy
old Navy and what's what's the name of
your General Mills the people who make
cereal okay that is so ridiculous I'm
actually gonna give you another chance
to lie the name of your general was Mike
General Mike General Mike Mills all
right look I'm too fascinated to stop
asking you these questions that you have
to make answer's up for where did he go
to boot camp camp boot you went to boot
camp in camp boot mmm old camp boot home
of the boot camp grant I'm just gonna go
ahead and save both of our times and
just change your application to a not
lie and say you've heard of a war not
fought in the war I have heard of war
I don't believe you but that's what
we're gonna put I'll just change the
form real quick if I could just you know
can you just lean forward just a little
bit me thank you that is perfect my fear
to go yes sir you look like a Toby Keith
song to GI Joe